alors deviner de cours on va parler
aujourd'hui deviner où on est voilà je
vous laisse regarder il ya de la place
d'arrière et puis là-bas on va il ya
plein mandat et sur le circuit de
barcelone aujourd'hui
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
test days on est au circuit de barcelone
est allé la journée de tests avec les
différentes écuries qui sont là il ya
toutes les grosses écuries
moi je suis venu avec mes recettes grèce
j'étais la chance
aujourd'hui 8 6
d'une écurie de f1
et tout ça en vous parlant de carsud
vraiment intéressant parce que au final
pour ce qui se passe est une chose qu'on
sait on comprend on voit la formule en à
télé mais il ya une vraie grosse
différence entre voir la formule en la
télé est rentré dans un garage dans les
coulisses voir lewis hamilton dans sa
voiture le temps garage avec tous les
techniciens autour en train de bosser en
train de lui mettre les pneus lui en
train de démarrer sa voiture et qu'il
est ça c'est vraiment totalement journée
vraiment exceptionnel merci qualcomm
mort permis de venir ici c'est
franchement hyper génial et vous allez
voir on n'est pas au goût de sortir
tout pour faire un détour du côté du
tout les environnements de l'équipe
mercedes vous à dire ça ça lui sinon là
on est sur le parti ingénieur vous avez
tout un un bâtiment dans lequel vous
avez tous le matos pour l'ingénierie la
flamme la partie équipe ne matic
alors ce qui est assez complètement ouf
là c'est qu'il va y avoir une
optimisation vous en douter au niveau
diplomatique
on en parlait dans toute la plus
technique de toute façon complètement
incapable mais c'est juste hallucinant
de voir le de l'intérieur réalité ce qui
se passe
[Musique]
aulas
tous les ingénieurs il n'y a pas une
partie à la notice travail comment
garage
il ya en tout 20 25 ingénieurs ils m'ont
dit tu travailles
ferrer la datar c'est à dire
pas la voiture elle ce soit sur les
précieux des pneus que ce soit
niveau 2 comme en face à votre héros il
vraiment hyper impressionnant écran vous
le voyez intérieur
ordinateurs d'une pierre concentré
regarder des chiffres c'est la loose
noir ailleurs miss kha doute terreur
par week-end de course c'est
hallucinant bon
il faut les récupérer il faut les
analyser pour pouvoir améliorer tout ça
et est en plus agir en temps réel moment
de la course parfaite hockey est juste
hallucinant
[Musique]
via saison qui va commencer d'ici deux
semaines si on s'entraîne vous avez
toutes les différentes équipes de f1 n'a
croisé lewis hamilton tout à l'heure au
niveau des ingénieurs et on a été faire
un petit tour thierry tôt dans une zone
malheureusement c'est pas pu filmer
j'aurais aimé que strictement interdite
pas de caméra pas qui courra du tout
dans le garage là ont tous passé les
voitures sont préparés y là où les
ingénieurs travaillent là où l'équipe
est là parce qu'à lui c'est en fait on
était assis
sur des deux rangées de sièges médias
casque à réduction de bruit bosse sur
les oreilles intercom on a pu écouter ce
qui se passe c'est exactement ce que
disaient les équipes
quelle manière il se préparait et le
tout est juste hallucinant fait parce
que ça existe de vaud
la f1 qui est là qui est posée le pilote
à l'intérieur il est lewis hamilton sa
voiture juste devant nous toute l'équipe
qui était à côté istres d'installer les
preuves qui était vraiment protégé pour
être à la bonne température c'était
hyper l'histoire on va toute l'équipe
qui s'affairent vraiment préparé cette
voiture dans les meilleures conditions
on installe les pneus sur place on
vérifie l'impression est encore plein de
détails que bien évidemment je suis très
loin de pouvoir deviner pour éviter de
perdre le nord à lille peine à démarrer
la voiture
nous disons bien aux produits au niveau
de l'échappement pour récupérer les gaz
il était donc soulevé tout le monde au
niveau du garage hamilton démarre la
voiture un bon ton d'en faire un héros
de syrte où est là qu ils partent
directement sur l'industrie il ya un
autre point de détail qui vachement
intéressant qui vraiment révélateur de
ce qui se passe c'est à dire que au
moment où la voiture est partie vous
avez tous les équipes qui sont en train
de nettoyer en fuite le sol on enlève
toutes les traces de doigts mots ont
remis un sac une absolue travaux on
pourrait presque arts et des techniques
et par totalement ses propos nous pousse
à retourner au garage
n est ce pas là d un peu aller voir des
vignerons toujours pas d'appareil photo
malheureusement on a ensuite été voir du
matériel au niveau des impôts aileron
arrière aileron avant très près comment
cet effet l'aileron arrière bien
évidemment toutankhamon extrêmement
léger et même du point de détail assez
intéressant c'est à dire l'épaisseur des
autocollants pour l'aérodynamisme pas
plus d'un millimètre
ok les normands et jean également pour
montrer vraiment la pression ont été
fabriquées pour l'aérodynamisme pour la
prise d'air viserait mondial sur terre
d'habitation des ministres
impressionnant et on a vu le siège
d'hamilton un siège est en carbone qui
est complètement moulée à sa morphologie
alors j'imagine que pilote
absolument parcours en 1 g pas grossir
parce que sinon le siège va plus
correspondre à l'idée d'avoir un siège
qui est vraiment boulet se lance pour
ses formes c'est de le protéger
au moment des courses donc à j'imagine
de vibrations qui dans le pire des cas
en cas d'accident et si jamais toutefois
ça devait arriver sortirait le siège
pourrait vous poser chine accueille les
braves pour l'arrivée des secours fall
qui est juste hallucinant on a supposé
le siège il pèse absolument rien on vous
a montré aussi les professions genou et
la position qu'il a dans sa voiture nous
explique qu'il est touché comme dans une
baignoire
il faut vraiment s'imaginer gens pour
hyper relaxe et puis vraiment peu en
avant un peu coucher oui c'est la fusion
à laquelle moi je m'endormirai dans ma
baignoire mais c'est la position dans
laquelle il a piloté sa réforme alors
bien évidemment on est une équipe on l'a
vu les nombreux casques en finlande
c'est un truc hallucinant je suis
heureux pour découvrir si aujourd'hui on
peut aussi perdre tous ses devoirs à la
région qui vont changer les pneus vous
avez
l'ennemi et encore c'était un peu trop
long pour changer d'air le chacal est à
son coach pour fait loupé et la voiture
repart directement près derrière vous
avez toute la partie à génieau technique
derrière la barre vous avez les garages
le circuit se passe là et là on a toute
la partie médias voilà et là je vous
parle là encore que de caunes leurs cds
vous avez tous les autres
baki
[Musique]
de martil
renault est fort juste réussir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
venu avec qualcomm merci beaucoup goal
com qui est partenaire de l'écurie f1
mercedes qui équipe mercedes en plein de
techno pour leur permettre de
communiquer la voiture le pilote et d'un
côté les ingénieurs alors là où je
marche c'est là où passe c'est là où les
voitures rentrer au garage elle rentre
aux stands alors c'est pour tout vert il
ya plein de monde là c'est une zone la
plus ouverte au public parce que ça
permet à tout le monde de venir un peu
de découvrir et là vous avez la ligne où
arrivent les votre cure pour arriver
directement au centre
elle arrive direct elles repartent
palabras et sinon ça va de la route
jusqu'à là bas
là vous avez volant pour trouver le plan
de lewis hamilton volant de f1 alors je
serai strictement incapable de vous dire
ce qu'on fait avec les boutons c'est
très compliqué c'est un métier j'ai la
chance de tenir je serais content voit
encore comme ça la griffe
ok donc regarder ses impressions et à
titre d'info un volant de la fin ça
coûte la bagatelle de 5 millions
[Musique]
oh
journée complètement folle
on a rencontré l lewis hamilton dans une
petite session de questions réponses des
cinq dix minutes on était quoi
quelques-uns cinq six sept personnes
dans une petite salle en face à face
avec lewis hamilton le mag franchement
hyper cool alors on lui a posé plein de
questions sur la technologie forcément
les geeks
il joue la ps4 là si ça peut vous
intéresser
c'est un grand fan de musique dans ses
déplacements fait musique qui a toujours
son ipod coûte beaucoup de musique et il
vient avec son clavier sa guitare tu
vois je savais pas que hamilton était un
musicien ça c'est plutôt cool mais très
abordable par contre tristement
impossible de publier une salle vidéo de
lui j'te publié des photos ou de lewis
hamilton absolument aucune vidéo un peu
frustrant néanmoins voilà je peux vous y
avait un mec plutôt cool j'aurais aimé
pouvoir vous diffuser une vidéo de lui
malheureusement pas possible
donc voilà bon en tout cas c'est
vraiment une expérience assez incroyable
de pouvoir être un peu à l'intérieur
pouvoir être dans le paddock dans le
motor home ou pouvoir vraiment découvrir
tout cet environnement
j'espère que ça pourra vous percez
vraiment un sujet très à part par
rapport à ce que je fais habituellement
mais de pouvoir rallier f1 sport
automobile technologies
c'est un vrai sens c'est vraiment cool
et merci beaucoup à mercedes afin de
m'avoir accueilli merci beaucoup à
qualcomm pour l'opportunité et dites moi
vous ce que vous en pensez en commencé à
ce que vous êtes fans de f1 est-ce que
vous suivez est ce que ça vous intéresse
est ce que vous êtes fan d'hamilton ce
que vous êtes fan de mercedes vous
marquez tout ça en commentaire ça donne
rendez vous demain nous embrasse ciao
[Musique]